[Music]
this is really the heart of america i
mean i think that's why i think that
separates fox news from any other show
or any other network that's doing a new
year's show we came to right where the
people are right here in in nashville
new orleans i mean this is where
america's heart is i'm out here these
people love fox these are our friends
this is what i love about this network
this party right here is america
this is americans unmasked and free
having a good time
tonight nashville stands in for sherman
texas in wichita kansas it stands in
from minnesota st paul minnesota it
stands for wisconsin and arizona every
state and every town across this country
that's who this party is for it's for
you that's right this is a reminder that
this is what america is about freedom
liberty i'm sorry i love our buddies in
new york lawrence um you know emily
they're doing a great job out there but
when you saw that mayor up there mast
and his family mass you go that's what
they want to do but right here in
nashville right here in the heart of
america people want to reclaim their
lives they want freedom they want to be
back they want the country back on track
and this gives me a lot of hope you're
right you look at time squared it feels
like
yesterday it feels like
remember when rumsfeld said old europe
it almost feels like if we're going to
renew america it's going to be in the
middle of the country it's going to be
with hardworking people with dirt under
their fingernails who love god who go to
church on sunday who work hard who love
the police who believe in citizens in
the border and and that's where we're
going to start again and that's what
makes me so enthused we are two and a
half minutes from 2022 making its way to
the central time zone to these people
partying rachel needs a rebound yeah
can we get a refill
rachel needs to reap me a little bit
i know you got a full one coming right
back
all right
here's your refill
hand me that
i got my refill
[Music]
i hope you all hear the music because
it's loud
i'm gonna get another refill hold on you
gonna eat one
two minutes
still two minutes two more
two minutes
in central time zone right here at the
wild horse room in nashville eddie
montgomery montgomery gentry singing my
town
to a wild crowd at the wild horse saloon
before we get going i just want to say
happy new year wisconsin we love you
happy new year arizona happy new year
texas
happy new year all of you in central
time we just love you so much and we
love that you guys tune in to us every
weekend
true you guys are our friends
it's god's country for sure
we're with you tonight and good on the
fox news channel for saying we're going
to do our big new years in central time
it's not just the east coast oh god
we're paying attention to and we are
almost
one minute to ringing in the new year of
2022. well really quickly what are you
looking forward to this year
i'm looking forward to absolutely
every aspect not just the three of us
and not just the fox news channel every
aspect of american culture turning the
page and putting rocket boosters under
our ambition our freedom and our
identity who we are getting back to
being america oh my gosh you just stole
mine i'm going to steal your resolution
i love it i'm going to drink to that i'm
going to drink to that
you're going to drink to that
uh
we should start carrying a cane
everywhere we go i like that at all
times i'm gonna work a little harder i
think i lift a little bit on the field
in 2021. you did yeah i needed to work a
little harder i think we all do shoulder
shoulder to the plow all right so it was
about we got almost 30 seconds almost 30
20 seconds
[Applause]
wow you guys look at that
happy new year
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
right here
[Music]
raise them up and sing along friends
so i strung up on my christmas
lights i've been drinking y'all come on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
roll up the streets
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
this town
[Music]
home cause i'm already here
[Music]
lock every bar in this town
[Music]
i don't care what you throw at us baby
you ain't gonna shut america down baby
that's just it
holders
a pac-man jimmy
and his garage
everybody's welcome